Sony's standalone venom movie has come
and gone and we all survived now let's
eat some lobsters and try to explain the
end of venom major spoilers ahead
switching sides by the movies climax the
goopy alien venom tells Eddie Brock that
he's ready to help humanity repel his
races invasion of Earth why according to
the alien it's because on his home
planet he's kind of a loser just like
Brock it's a great line but it doesn't
really explain the pivotal moment
however it could have some roots in the
comics in venom first host number one we
learned that the symbiote that would
eventually become venom was cast out
from the rest of its gloopy brothers and
sisters possibly the result of some kind
of cognitive damage as a result Venom's
never really been quite like the rest of
the Marvel comic symbiotes we'd met of
course none of that sounds as good as
Ben I'm calling himself a loser so it
didn't make it into the script
taylean nation life foundation head
honcho Carlton Drake was up to his
armpits and symbiotes for most of the
movie but by the end only riot and
Benham remained so you may be wondering
what happened to the rest well
apparently the symbiotes couldn't live
in their given host and died which kind
of makes riots plan to steal a rocket
and bring a whole bunch more anaerobic
symbiotes to an oxygen-rich planet
filled with incompatible hosts kind of
dumb
you suck but enough about all that did
you see the park where venom chomped on
some guy's head that was great that
red-haired bozo so what's the deal with
Woody Harrelson and that bright red wig
during the first post-credit scene well
that dear friends was Cletus Kasady
a mass murderer who eventually becomes
the super villain named carnage carnage
is yet another symbiote and even goofier
evil or offspring of the venom life-form
that's right y'all Venom's gonna be a
mom despite the fact that all the other
symbiotes died in this movie we know
that if Sony decides to greenlight a
venom sequel we've just met the lead
villain a lethal protector venom had a
pretty hard time keeping his violent
urges in check for the majority of the
film's release critics
the time the Bodega seen at the end is a
clear example of that since mrs. chin
sees Eddie's transformation and heavy
eating habits so is Eddie going public
with his alter ego venom the short
answer is well maybe we know from the
comics especially the lethal protector
story from the 1990s that Brock's
identity as venom was known to the
residents of San Francisco though more
is an unstable monster than a lovable
creep the end of the movie seemed to
indicate that the film franchise may be
going this route as well at least as far
as folks in his San Francisco
neighborhood are concerned MCU later
so as venom in the MCU sure Sony and
Marvel Studios agreed to share Spidey
for a few MCU movies but spider-man's
supporting characters remain a
continuity mystery since Sony owns their
movie rights and Marvel doesn't there's
really no clear answer to this even by
the movies in no one mentions Tony Stark
or shield so Venom's connections to the
wider Marvel Universe are thin to
non-existent but no one mentioned
spider-man either in the end venom seems
to take place in its own little
dimension so all you super fans hoping
to see Doctor Strange team-up with venom
are probably out of luck unless into the
spider verse Venom's second post credit
scene teased the animated spider-man
into the spider verse which teams up
different versions of Spider Man from
across the multiverse and the comics
it's based on had more than just comic
book Spidey's including guys like the
Spider Man from the 1970s Japanese TV
show at least a couple cartoon
spider-man and even the spider-man from
Capcom's fighting games there was a
Spider Man for every fan so what's this
got to do with venom
well the Spidey's from sony's previous
to spider-man movie franchises Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield can
theoretically connect up with Tom
Holland spider-man and while Spiderman
didn't show up in this movie into the
spider verse still connects all of them
to venom venom may never share a
milkshake with Drax the destroyer but
you can rest easy knowing that somewhere
in the far reaches of the spider verse
it just might happen
[Music]